welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is piotre Purdue a professor of history
at Yale University professor Purdue is
the author of two widely acclaimed books
exhausting the earth state and peasant
in hunan 1500 to 1850 ad and China
marches West the Ching conquest of
central Eurasia he has also written on
grain markets in China agricultural
development and environmental history
professor Purdue's research interests
lie in modern Chinese and Japanese
social and economic history the history
of frontiers and world history today
we'll talk with him about tea
cultivation in China welcome professor
Purdue thank you you've written an essay
entitled is par Enzo Mia and it looks at
the sum of the association's cultural
and economic associations of tea
particularly from an a historical
perspective let's begin with defining
what porous and then what so Mia is yes
well poo are is a kind of tea that's
grown in Yunnan Province in South China
and today it's a very popular tea in
China and has a great deal of value on
the tea market for connoisseurs it can
even sell for thousands of dollars per
ounce so Mia is a region that was
defined by the political scientist Jim
Scott here at Yale and some other people
that includes the hill lands of both
northern South East Asia and South China
which union is a part of so the basic
question in this paper is and I put in
those strange words just to attract
attention really got my attention
they're both new words unfamiliar ones
but the basic ideas if there's tea
cultivation in the southern region of
China and also this very special quality
of this hill zone and he
a global product of course what is the
relationship between this kind of global
trade and the hill zones of south china
and northern Southeast Asia ok given
your scholarly background how are you
drawn to this particular topic well my
two previous books one was on Hunan
which is in central China now but was
more of a frontier zone back in the 16th
century and the second book is on the
conquest of central Eurasia modern
mongolia and shenyang so both of my two
previous books were about frontier
regions of China pretty much on the edge
of the Empire at the time and how they
got incorporated and made part of the
main empire and in a way the T project
is a little bit of an extension of that
it looks at another frontier region
south china the hill lands and how this
particular trade route can brought in
some of the people of that region into
what is really a very major global trade
today ok and let's talk a little bit
about the methodology are there other T
studies that you were able to draw on
how did you go about doing the research
for the paper well they're actually lots
and lots of books about t there are a
lot of popular books you know which are
all a great fun to read and most of them
focus on the british basically the idea
of course the British who went to China
to buy the tea in the 19th century and
then grew the tea in India for
themselves really started the opium war
in China in order to pay for the tea so
the vast majority of studies are from
the british point of view and the
Chinese sources on tea itself haven't
actually been looked at very much and I
think a lot of the studies of tea don't
really get the entire picture of how t
is a product of China but a global
commodity at the same time ok so you use
some of you drew on some of the existing
research but how did you go about
writing the paper did you did you
actually visit these areas for instance
well no I'm really at the very beginning
stages of this I certainly I definitely
want to go to you none
back and see the T regions at some point
and I've looked at published sources and
libraries but I haven't been to the
archives yet to look for T related
sources and I'm just beginning to look
at other secondary primary sources on a
subject now okay and I am curious to
know about another beverage you
mentioned in the essay called Mauti or
am out I know time what is it and how is
it related to tea well this is I guess
how I got interested in this subject in
the first place now ty is actually a
very hard liquor powerful liquor
distilled from sorghum and sorghum is
actually a plant by students don't know
about though it looks like American corn
on the stalk but it's a grain brewed or
eaten all over China and when I first
went to china in the early days of the
opening of china mouth i was very
popular a very high-priced luxury drink
that they would serve you at all these
chinese banquets okay and even when
Nixon went to China I believe multi was
the premier drink served at the banquets
to welcome him to China it was actually
made in South China also in this
frontier zone today if you go to China I
think it's more likely and this was what
happened to me your friends will start
giving you party instead of multi if you
tell them you like tea they say oh have
you tried to our because this is really
the highest quality kind of stuff so why
was there this switch you know from this
really powerful bicker example as the
premier sort of banquet drink to
something like poo are that's that's
what really got me interested in this
subject in the first place and what is
it well it's a cultural shift i would
say i know the communist party when they
came to power before they came to power
even were in the northwest part of China
where sorghum grew and cruder rotgut
versions of mouth i were really the main
kind of liquor that the local peasants
drank and they grew up on this stuff and
that's what they thought they would want
to have for themselves and when they
were giving banquets and everything
they would want the highest quality of
this really North Chinese sorghum liquor
but now the Communist Party of course
still in power but has changed its
culture and wants to look more
sophisticated I think and be more
attractive to global audiences and T has
had all of course these ancient cultural
associations with China so so it's not
so much the party now but businessman
everybody officials who promotes Chinese
tea culture as kind of the essence of
Chinese today okay and what do you think
the shift from the mouth tie to the high
quality TV shows mm-hmm well I thought I
wish it would show that maybe Chinese
officials are getting less drunk than
they used to be but I could not prove
that data at this point but the image
that China wants to project to the world
certainly and I think even the kinds of
products that Chinese people consume
today have changed drastically over the
last 30 years whereas they had a much
simpler cuisine in certain ways under
the Maoist period that was grains melt I
made from grains it was a few vegetables
a little bit of pork and chicken now of
course they're consuming all sorts of
different products including a lot more
meat and seafoods and rare goods and so
they've always had these luxury
connoisseur tastes but now a lot more
Chinese are much wealthier they're
consuming the foods of the world in fact
okay let's talk a little bit about the
social life of tea what does it Ellis
trait in terms of the hill country or as
Omiya in connection with urban tea
houses well this is the connection i
think hasn't been made all that often
but tea is very famous in China as a
drink for scholars for literary literary
people you know
it and it is a stimulant to keep you
awake so you can read more longer
originally was drunk in monasteries by
Buddhist so they could meditate so it
always has these high-level associations
with religion and a literary scholarship
but most of the best tea in China
everyone agrees comes from the hills and
these are very remote and backward
places very poor often and often the
people who pick the ter not even Chinese
they are very poor mountain people who
were brought in to pick the crops so I
to get the total story of tea we do want
to talk about the consumption side but
if you look at the production side in
the Hills then you have this link to
this is omean hill country which has
these very special kinds of peoples who
are quite distinct from the urban
lowland consumers okay have you you've
actually had polarity yes i'm actually a
fan of it okay i'm dying to try it not
really ready try sir can you describe
what it tastes like well the even the
terms used to describe it today are
quite fascinating I would say most of my
friends who try it would use terms like
Earth or tobacco or other lower level
terms that's like you know what it is an
earthy drink are very different from the
standard green tea but the promoters of
who are often use the wine vocabulary
all these things that you see attached
to two fine French wines with the the
flavors of anise and orange and a little
bit of Earth and the sunshine all the
California French wine terminology is
now applied to part and make it look
like the similar kind of very
sophisticated product marketing yeah
it's all it's all marketing but they're
mixing together this Chinese and global
marketing vocabulary fascinating and
what do you conclude in your essay is
poo Aaron zonia well if Zambia means
geography and that was the original
ideas that it's it's a particular kind
of region at a Highland zone in China
then the source of who are is in
somya but Jim Scott has other ideas
about what Sonia is that zoe has special
kinds of people in it he says there are
people who avoid the state his book ends
Oh Mia is an anarchist history of
Southeast Asia these are refugees owns
shatter zones where people go to get
away from states and markets the people
producing porn I'm not so sure that's
true they are actually involved in
commerce after all even the pickers and
the merchants and the consumers and
there are these links that connect the
domain region to the lowlands the rivers
the ports and the rest of the world so
it's a it's a link between the zone Ian
region and the rest of the world I think
okay well I will have to try someone try
it if you like it yes thank you so much
for being here with us today and sharing
some of your work oh thank you very much
thanks for any be here for more
information about professor Prudhoe and
his work please visit our website at
Yale that edu backslash Macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you